ونحن نتابع مسار القصف والتصعيد الغير
مسبوق في القطاع ولكن في الوقت نفسه هناك
سحب لويه لواء ان سحبا من خان يونس كيف
يفسر
هذا يعني انا بتقديري الانسحابات تاتي في
سياق انسحاب اللواء الجولاني يعني ك هي
نفس الظروف تقريبا اللواء الجولاني حينما
انسحب لم يحقق
اهدافه كان هناك خسائر كبيره في صفوف هذا
اللواء اي معنويات الجنود انخفضت كفاءته
القتاليه تدنت كثيرا بالحسابات العسكريه
اضطروا الى سحبه وشاهدناه كيف رقصوا
وابتهجوا حينما انسحبوا من الشجاعيه وهذا
كان معيبا ان يرقص ويفرح الضابط والجندي
حين ينسحب من الميدان دون ان يحقق اهدافه
وما شاهدناه اليوم في نفس السياق يرفعون
الاعلام و مبتهجين مبسوطين طبعا طريقه
الانسحاب لا تشي بان هذا الجيش يعني حقق
اهدافه على الارض بالعكس هذا جيش مهزوم في
طريقه انسحابه في طريقه رفع الاعلام انا
بتقديري حتى تزويد الاعلام لكل جندي
اسرائيلي هي من اجل رفع المعنويات ومن اجل
ارسال رساله للجبهه الداخليه الاسرائيليه
لكن انا بتقديري الجبهه الداخليه
الاسرائيليه اكثر ما يعرف بانه الجيش
الاسرائيلي بعد 114 يوم ينسحب من ارض
المعركه دون ان يحقق اهدافه هو صحيح قتل
ارتكب مجازر جرائم حرب سياسه ارض محروقه
حرب اباده جماعيه ولكنه لم يقاتل لم يقاتل
لم يقاتل الجندي الاسرائيلي المقاومين
المقاومين هم الذين قاتلوه هم الذين نصبوا
له الكمائن وقنص دباباته وقتلوا وجرحوا
ودمروا الدبابات والجرافات والاليات واسقط
الطائرات ويخفون الصوريخ في كليه الرد من
جانب المقاومين في هذه المرحله من
الحرب يعني بالتاكيد حينما نتحدث اخت
ليلله عن 114 يوم ومقاومه فلسطينيه
امكانياتها متواضعه في ظل ظروف غايه في
التعقيد والصعوبات يعني المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لا يعيش في بحبوحه الجندي
الاسرائيلي الجندي الاسرائيلي يتحصن
بالدبابه وبالمدفع وباليه وتحميه الطائره
وفيه البحريه ولكن المقاوم الفلسطيني يخرج
من تحت انقاض يعيش حياه صعبه ومع كل ذلك
يطلق صواريخه يطلق مدفعيته ينصب الكمائن
يشتبك مع الجنود الاسرائيليين من مسافات
قريبه
ويقصف الدبابات والاليات وهي متحركه
ومعروف في العلم العسكري الاهداف المتحركه
من اصعب الاهداف لانها تحتاج الى تقييم
دقيق وسريع للسرعه سرعه المقذوف وسرعه
الدبابه ويجب ان تتواءم معها وهذه انا
بتقديري يعني رسائل ترسل للجيش الاسرائيلي
وصناع القر
انه بعد هذه الايام والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
يستطيع ان يقوم بهذه الاعمال انا بتقديري
هذا انجاز عسكري يحسب للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
ويضرب الروح المعنويه عند صناع القرار
اولا قبل الضباط وقبل الجنود الاسرائيليين